right so we're finishing up with today
and today is the day where we tie
together all the different threads
started out the groundwork by saying he
wanted to find the fundamental principle
of morality I think you've seen that
through that for him that's the
categorical imperative by the end of the
groundwork he talks about the phrases
that he wants to find he wants to take
us to the extreme limit of all moral
enquiries so a pretty ambitious project
right he's going to find the unifying
principle that brings everything else
together he's going to take us to the
extreme limit of moral inquiry which is
not just figuring out what's right and
wrong as we're gonna see today this has
to do with who Artin what kind of thing
or what kind of being and how should you
be looking at the world and other people
that's pretty big stuff and so cons has
this this project which by the way I
want to stress I'm not a conscious I
don't agree with certain parts of this
and I think that some of you don't as
well but you certainly have to admire or
appreciate his his willingness to like
put it all out there yeah take a very
strong principled stand you know where
cannot stands on just about everything
that we're going to have to look at you
may not agree with that but you don't
have to it's a good thing to know this
is one way to think about duty one way
to think about what the human person is
so we're going to talk a little bit
about the category we're not going to
look at examples
we're gonna look at these two ideas
autonomy person and so just to give you
kind of an overview what is that you
guys heard that word before right
probably I have used it a lot in
conversation but what is it to be
autonomous welcome to music politically
and we talk about it autonomous province
where people want economy your I can
apply to individuals being autonomous
means
like Texas want to become an autonomous
state again whichever one that would
mean that they would decide everything
for themselves so for a person to be
autonomous is choosing for yourself not
having somebody else to choose for you
right when you're a kid where you have
finals everyone was telling you what to
do right teachers parents then other
authority figures other kids have the
time tell me what to do
TV was telling you what to do find this
right now maybe you can go to your
parents to pester them for that cereal
my ears we weren't happy enough none of
us believe that a human person
I think that's an easier matter but
there's you notice I didn't put human
being becomes you and everybody else all
human people persons or something
greater that other so I've used this
before as an example you know let's
pretend that it's you know twenty years
beyond this and now something this size
has got you know ten billion times the
capabilities that that's something
yes now he would still not be worth what
you are they would not be the first even
if it was self-aware I'm not even sure
to compensate it would be a person
because to be a person has to do with
not only being self-aware but with
having it will with having a free will a
rational a will that can decide between
right and wrong
yeah which can change itself and that
that's part of what makes you you this
permit makes you similar to everybody
else but it's also what makes you who
you are
and gives you the dignity the worth
that's beyond any amount of my problems
or you know state lesser examples only--
biscotti or books you know if you go to
the library for example tons of books
books both looks a lot more knowledge
than you have right one of the
depressing things about going to the
library any of you in your majors walk
and you know little stacks and you look
at those rows of books are like man I
can never read all of these remember
half of the stuff that I read anyway I
did like it's been the whole rest of my
life just learning about abnormal
psychology or you know the laws behind
doing business in foreign countries or
this or that you know the history of
this particular people or that that's
what stuff it can become the precedent
you realize you couldn't master all
that's not worth as much as you even if
you didn't know any of that stuff you
have a worth that goes beyond any mere
physical thing any product any animal so
that's what we're gonna look at today
that's part of what makes you what you
are it makes everyone else with what
they are and I'm gonna I'm going to skip
around a little bit we're going to be
going through parts of section two that
we didn't get to before and we're going
to go into section three and then we're
going to come back for a portion of
section two so he talks about the
kingdom events and you're going to see
him use this terminology over there and
where do we see this term having to come
up before remember the second
formulation of the cat
act always so as to treat humanity in
yourself and in others never as a means
alone but always as a net and we talked
about that last time in terms of like
using me right so if here's an example
that may be able to relate to if I were
to turn the professor-student
relationship into something just to
benefit me to get something that I want
or to benefit you because I want
something back from you I would be
treating you common say in an immoral
way of treating you as merely it means a
tool an instrument for my my desires of
my inclinations and I can do this with
very drastic ways like I could say okay
everybody wants to pay alright how much
are you willing to pay for an a what's
the dollar amount that you'd be willing
to shell out load be using it right it'd
be using a lot of things you know
abusing my position using the good
offices of the university but you would
be using you would be treating you as
something less valuable than you are you
would be reducing the relationship of
educator to student to something purely
instrumental
if I were just to show up here and do
kind of a song in the answer mouth and
that put stuff into idler and not
develop resources for you and just put
it in my time and you know do the
minimal amount of work and get you in
and get you out making a paycheck and
maybe I would justify it by saying well
I'm not making what the professors are
making because I'm an adjunct so I'm not
going to give you you know what the
professors are giving you you're gonna
get exactly your money's worth out of me
how would you feel cheated yeah because
we can't get the education no matter
who's in that's true yeah yeah that's
true you could maybe that could be your
good retort to me then and then still be
at the level of money I think this would
go beyond money that's interesting if
I'm not going to put in the work why
should it could be that there's an
educator one of my duties not about a
strict duty but a meritorious duty is to
convey that I care about things that
we're studying it actually makes it
easier for you to carry invisible you
see the professor cares it's easier for
you to care one reason why I tend to
dress up not feeling well yes I want to
convey the seriousness of what we're up
to
but how else would you feel you do feel
cheated you would feel you didn't get
your money's worth
unenthusiastic would you feel angry
upset I think so why would you feel that
way I think you would feel that way in
part because you felt like I was
treating it like you didn't matter this
is why we get angry they're treating us
in a way that we don't deserve that we
deserve what if I were to be really fun
and do really entertaining lectures that
you might learn a little bit from
because I really like being up on stage
and having an appreciative audience you
know a fun class that was great you
might like that more I think
what I still be treating it as a means I
did that I would be treating you as a
means to satisfying my own vanity or
desire to have approval or things like
that
the only way I'm possibly going to treat
you as an end in a situation as an
educator is if I actually educate you if
I actually which was not by the way
there's cram acknowledged into your head
it's a back and forth process it's
trying to bring stuff out of you it's
trying to set things up in such a way so
as to elicit from you the kind of
activity that will result in you
learning if I'm not doing that I'm
treating you as less than a person I'm
treating you is just something to get
something out of right there's lots of
ways we can think about this so the
second formulation of categorical
imperative it's saying you ought to
treat other people as as one other part
of that is s in myth autonomy this is an
example I used in the last class for you
guys for me to respect your autonomy
means that I have to recognize that you
are also a being with freewill now if
I'm going to try to get you to see
things a certain way I can't do it by
rewarding or punishing you I can't do it
by yelling at you I can't do
by forcing you or coercing you I have to
try to get you to do it through
persuasion yeah and it has to be
rational persuasion not just appealing
to your emotions or your desires or
things like that I have to ultimately
sort of place the opportunity in front
of you and either you take it or you
don't you have a free will and you don't
take it and I come down on you hard for
not taking it I'm not really respecting
your autonomy then am I so again we as a
pedagogical example I think you've all
had some professors but I've done this
professor at one point thank God I've
gotten away from that you've all had
professors who thought that you should
care and be interested in the material
as they are right in their subjects so
if they really like Beowulf and you are
not getting everything out available
that they're getting out of it there's
something wrong with you there's nothing
wrong with the book there's something
wrong with you and they're gonna make
sure that you dump it right have you
guys had this professor like I said I've
been this professor great one point now
let's think about this class played over
with Aristotle and cotton mill and
Jeremy Bentham live actually I don't
know I know that interesting agreed
myself would it make sense for me to
insist that you should enjoy reading
this this stuff as much as the idea of
thinking about this stuff and
you should make ethics sort of the
centerpiece of your life and if you
don't you're a bad person you're a bad
student you don't belong here at the
University and sudden redsetter you've
all heard this sort of thing before I
seen because we lose it sometimes well
you know if I did that I would not be
treating you as a being with autonomy
I don't be treating you in some ways it
means I would not be treating you as a
person who's able to choose for
themselves Khan would say that if I'm
teaching conte and I get something out
of cut I should hope that you'll get
something else but I can't make you do
it if I try to make you do it that I'm
actually going against God's very own
notions of autonomy I've been treating
you as somebody who I could I could
control like it coerce wouldn't be
leaving you here on time it wouldn't be
in service certainly respecting and I
think that's probably if you were to
think about that sort of educational
situation one of the words you would
probably use to describe it as the
professor was not respectful of students
right they wanted respect for the
material and then one of the students to
respect the material but they didn't
treat the students respectfully and that
usually you know makes it not work
the compensates not wrong because it
doesn't work I would say is wrong
because it doesn't respect the students
he has autonomous as a person it treats
the student as somehow less than a
person now you know where does the where
does the line begin I don't you treat
elementary students the same way as
college students god no pandemonium you
make them do things then at a certain
point it has to be left to you and
you're you're on the early end of this
but as you get
you're engaged in more and more
relationships and roles you will find
yourself constantly in situations where
you want to say all right this this
letting people choose stuff this is not
working
somebody's gotta you know step in and
restore order and make things happen the
right way you know when we let people
choose what they're going to do things
don't turn out fine
so I'm gonna make a cap and then you'll
see that that doesn't actually pan out
that well and if you remember your Conte
which I hope you do at that time you
know think about treating people
autonomously there's a reason they don't
like it because they're not treating
them with respect I got 30 minutes was a
human person so cat talks about this in
terms of a kingdom of ends right and I
think that this this notion of Kingdom
we don't live in kingdoms what
communities so can they exist in a
community events where we treat each
other with a certain sort of respect a
certain level of dignity a certain
recognition of being a human person
that's what that's what today is about
how does that happen
and Khan thinks that the categorical
imperative is the way in which we're
going to be able to to make this happen
so this brings up an important concept
that talks about value or price now
you're all familiar with things having a
value to apprentice this is almost
worthless as a little piece of chalk but
still cost something
we made they keep finding these in my
pocket you know if it was worth anything
the university or the college wouldn't
let me take them home all the time in 5
min my pocket imagine if a desk was
missing each side then they'd get
concerned with because that has a higher
value or price this has a certain value
I'll make this go okay notice to it it
can shift depending on the situation if
you compare this to the disco need to
get across the street at Starbucks if
you like the machine made stuff that has
you know a little chocolate on top of it
I think it's about 115 right you really
really like Starbucks yeah I have to
admit there's one thing I like the
Banana River the chocolate chips anyway
so this is going right this could have a
certain price yeah you know a lot of
people are the homemade stuff this looks
kind of irregular but maybe that's a
sound and if you put this on the
internet and put like a nice wrapping
around it you might get three four bucks
for this it's better where you play
which is you know huge markup you know
you realize how great the markups are
to make yes sir no sir in price you can
exchange this against other the fact
that we've exchanged money for things
shows us that you can substitute all
these other things for if I don't have
this biscotti I could have another
discovery you know somebody likes the
Starbuck the stability more then maybe I
can make him a deal so I'll give you two
of these for one of those we can
exchange the man this has a certain
exchange value and only an exchange
value this doesn't have an intrinsic
worth like you news this is worth an
awful lot more and how many of us Cody
would you swap against an iPhone even
granted it's an iPhone 3 coming out
what's up yeah you're right he would
depend on factors right and it would
depend on how much you want the biscotti
at the moment you're really hungry
you're loving sold for less this
building again CI if your CI for free
it's a three yeah well they are on
contract oh yeah but it actually costs
money outside of contracts oh yeah
because the contract subsidizes a good
thing right it's all in terms of dollar
values and we can talk about other
values as well think about a good friend
that you have
why do you value your friend is it
because they're really irreplaceable and
you couldn't do with you know somebody
else in their place let's drop it down a
little bit think about hanging out with
you just want to hang out with somebody
you call your friends they can't hang
out with you that day you should call
somebody else right you can put somebody
else in their place you can tell whether
somebody really needs to be say in a
wedding party
the bridesmaid and groomsman they get
sick can somebody else step in take the
job sure unless it really really really
matters to you that this person be there
you know that this person has to be the
best man or maid of honor
Thanks bridesmaid is a serve engineer ya
know so if you say this person I can't I
can't have the wedding unless they're
the you know the maid of honor then he
would say that there's no price there's
no possibility of substitution but when
push comes to shove if you really want a
wedding and then that you know there's
only two people that can't have only
three people that can't show up right
the bride the groom and whoever is doing
the wedding everybody else is pretty
much optional or exchangeable they don't
you know they they could be replaced by
somebody else now
think about for example some other
things like romantic or sexual relations
if all you want is the physical pleasure
that goes with us then anybody will do
right so long as they satisfy a certain
criteria they fit within your range of
whatever your preferences are but you
know if person a who satisfies those
preferences is an available person he
would do just as well one thing that's
that's having a price now think about
some of the things that go along
sometimes with romantic relationships or
sexual relationships
if you develop intimacy with that that
person you truly get to know who they
are or you're just in the process of
getting to know who they are you
actually wanna know more and more about
them and they want to know more more
experience something like this at
certain point it's kind of like
friendship but it goes a little bit
beyond friendship in a different way how
we're at the level of something that
can't be exchanged you lose that person
what are your friends sometimes there's
a lot of fish in the ocean yeah but I
want this fish this is the only fish
that's going to do for me if you were
they actually saying yeah you're right
I've been a lot of fish and you know I'm
gonna find something else to be into
them but not just you know to be
romantic whether sexual full intimacy
somebody else looking at them and saying
well you don't really understand what
intimacy yes dear you're missing
something there right that's because
there's certain aspects of us that can't
price
and now college is not going to figure
this in terms of like intimacy or things
like that I just want to use that as an
example I think it's easier to relate to
what cut is going to place here in fact
that we have free well as rational
beings and the fact that we can be more
we this is a plus twice for a commitment
you don't have to be bored and you can
do the right thing for the wrong reason
that's your choice that's part of what
it means to be on top of it not only
that you can just go right and choose
the right thing for the right reason but
also that you can go wrong even horribly
to recognize so many as being autonomous
means you recognize this entire range
and possibility that's what gives us our
particular dignity or worth and if
that's what gives me my dignity or worth
that's what gives her her biggest fear
that's what makes her equal to me or him
or young or any one of us or that poor
mom out on the street who you know who
stinks and there's probably you know if
you leave anything oh this is gonna
steal it he still is a rational being
with free will it has the potential to
be moral could be autonomous turn
addictions he was just as much of a
human person yes am i or are you that's
something that that countess thing this
was very revolutionary for him to say
that's I mean remember that this is the
late 1700s the slavery is still a common
practice across most of the world at
this time if you're not a slave
relationship you're probably
on a certain master relationship a lot
of classism Kaunas is asserting that we
all have as human beings we all have the
same human dignity we may not do the
same things with it we all have us every
single human being by virtue of being
human so that's that's part of what he
means by this kingdom of X it's to
imagine a world in which we treat each
other and truly human ways not to be
moral means that we give ourselves laws
or rules which we follow and that ties
in with this thing about rational
because reason is how we discover those
that's where the categorical imperative
came in right act always on the maps
when you can at the same time will it be
a universal law of nature that's not
something that you learn by experience
is it by watching the world that's
something you derive by it by reason
actually you do derived in this or you
know riveter derivative way by getting
it from once you understood it you can
say yeah that makes that makes sense do
you have a choice whether you do that or
not absolutely so these three things
rational free will
Laurel giving yourself laws and right
guys they are intimately connected
together and that's what gives you your
your value as a human person now I want
to move ahead actually into section
three this is where I think it gets it
gets really interesting
so indeed if we talk about autonomy
what's the opposite of that Greek auto
itself atropine
so if autonomies is the condition of
giving yourself rules governing yourself
choosing for yourself being free and
using that freedom to decide things
heteronomy is when somebody else is
giving you the rules somebody else is
saying you have to you have to do this
you have to do that now if you already
free being and somebody else is giving
you rules and you're following those
rules
you aren't freely choosing to follow
those rules for instance I want to sort
of dwell on this if for instance I say
if you don't do what I say I'm going to
kill you you still have a choice right
you can say he left me without a choice
where you know think about the Godfather
famous wine makes somebody an offer they
can't refuse well actually they can
refuse the only thing is there's
consequences to refusing it if I hold
the gun to your head and I say complete
this exam or I'm going to kill you bad
professor professor you would still have
a choice you would be on some level
accepting that if you want this you have
to do this you would be accepting
somebody else's rule you would be freely
doing there are certain ways we can do
this that sort of remove our are our
freedom from us you know if you start if
you say I'm free to do anything I want
so I'm gonna smoke crack or take heroin
or
you know it was crystal meth very
quickly you're gonna cease being an
autonomous being in a real sense any
sort of you know sets other than purely
potential because you're going to become
addicted those are those are three of
the worst ones to get involved with
because they're so addictive and their
effects are just devastating on people's
lives right the big three then you would
be quite a type of heteronomy addiction
is form of pattern I think of other
things you could be addicted to be
cycling of substances yeah
and that's been a problem for a long
time I remember just reading in one of
the strangest places you'd expect it
with it was a commentary on the
commentary on Ecclesiastes by some I
don't even remember which author was
talking about it and he talked about
people feeling bad and eating therefore
because they felt that you know it seems
tough that we talked about today has
been around for a little money yeah
people become addicted to food yeah does
anybody start off by saying to
themselves you've all seen those clothes
commercials instead of Buddy Hughes to
be a junkie right at the start no but
they make that first step and then they
choose another stuff and they're using
their free will and invention places
them in a situation where now they feel
a compulsion that's very very difficult
to resist people can become addicted to
sacks
yeah
that's a good question
I think I would say as a physical being
there could be a sort of threshold after
which you just can't control yourself I
think that would be a lot more inclined
to say that's pretty far down the line
and a lot of what we call addiction is
really something more like having a very
strong desire and then not standing up
against it when you could actually do it
it would be very hard to do so but it
gets progressively harder and harder
than yeah it's been questionable yeah
you want it losing on freewill
specifically or is that part of your
life not just because of the things they
have the free will to choose that
whether or not you're going to smoke
crack but you know you can't choose
anymore your body pretty much meat there
yeah well you need in order to operate
in order to feel okay
right but you could still choose not to
operate I guess whenever they're heroin
addicts who have a heroin that they need
withdrawal symptoms from interest I was
in here people die when they find yeah
after all but people do in fact choose
it I mean that shows us that people do
have the capacity isn't it's not just
the sense of underplay how difficult it
is or anything like that or how most
strongly urges people
and shoes like people that protect
themselves very difficult to do joy yeah
so so there's there's sort of two things
going on there's there's this this
physical one thing there's this physical
set of causes and effects that the
producer desires incarnations of us and
that there's this little sliver this
tiny little sliver free of all that's
left but so long as there's even a
sliver of it there's still the capacity
for charts oh yeah gambling addiction
that's that's playing video games that
people do become addicted to video games
actually even internet like Facebook and
Twitter there's there's you know
discussions of whether they're addictive
and they've found that texting song
college students are neither a
chronically sleep-deprived because they
get taxes in the middle of the night
from their other friends who are
chronically sleep-deprived and then they
feel this compulsion to answer these
texts or actually just to see what it is
so they don't get enough sleep yeah so
are we staying on the you truly never
lose pretty well you always have I think
regardless yeah here's a place where I
think I would different from now I think
probably most of you would like I said
I'm not a conscious I can go with him up
to a certain point I think at this point
I'd be willing to say that a person can
eventually lose that
and they can become in that sense this
is actually a good statement they will
become a purely physical courier and
doing cop talks about Pinkham danger
where everything is was and the fact and
some of these are purely physical and
some of these are what we call
psychological thanks you know if I if
I'm going to change your personality
yeah
you don't bring washing in the sense of
somebody putting a pattern or
conditioning which you are not able to
then resist and have to follow would be
removing here autonomy ironically we say
a person like that is like an automaton
all right
meaning a robot but we changed the
meaning of determine you would be
controlled by it by something the
outside pick yeah in a case like that
you could say that the person person he
hasn't done their free will removed
entirely because if you're able to
remove that conditioning then they would
be able to exercise for you but they're
not able to actively exercise yeah
that's a good example of the kind of
conditioning that we often call
brainwashing are you guys all familiar
with this this movie book there's a guy
named criminal and they do the
experimental procedure on him movies
even sitting in the chair they've got
like his I can't not look at the screen
and they start showing all these these
violent reactions and they use chemicals
to make him feel sick when he sees the
things that he used to love like hitting
people
rape vandalism all these sorts of things
and then they turn him out and now he's
at the mercy of all of his old friends
it's conditioning and Gigi wants to hit
people and every time it does he feels
physically ill but you still like you
know choosing the hips
well I mean if you laid out to somebody
if you do X Y Z these consequences will
follow and they say that it's your
choice I think you should follow this
but I'm leaving it up to you I just want
you to be aware you're going to kill
people on our community we're going to
lock you up compensate that's not that's
actually respecting that's treating them
he has a moral being that's saying look
these are the consequences the society
cannot have people wandering around
let me let me go back to them to this so
yes human being right you have bodies
and part of that body is that that brain
of yours that makes you so different
from the other animals and you're able
to do a lot of very complex thinking
that you just sort of take for granted
with that that brain and that's where
your a lot of your personality resides
right some of it also has to do with you
know what hormones are in your system at
the time other chemicals are interacting
your memories are stored there I think
you probably think of your memories is
something that makes you who you are
would you be in a real sense so but
that's you know your memories are sort
of the physical way and that's subject
to all these laws of cause and effect
and even the way in which you've behaved
psychologically give certain drives and
desires right all of you want to eat
sleep at certain times you want to have
sex you want to find out what's going on
over there you know as a curiosity drive
or desire as matter of fact these can
often interact in complex ways you're in
a restaurant and you see somebody else
over there at the other
table there dish looks pretty good now
do you want to know what is that over
there because I might want to eat it
myself you know
or somebody you're sitting at the same
table and the dessert comes and their
dessert looks better than yours and now
you you want to know what is their
dessert tastes like okay those are all
pretty much you can think of those in
terms of the body or in terms of the
psyche personality if I want to change
your personality I think I could change
your brain chemistry and then probably
produce some interesting changes if you
want to make a healthy person into a
vegetable you give them lithium you ever
seen anybody who doesn't need lithium
you put on with you it's this horrifying
them to watch it occurs to them I want
to make you happier I can you know
increase your serotonin levels your
dopamine levels antidepressants that's
part of what they do keep the dopamine
from
Sarat all models and then people feel
happier and that's all that's all
physical Elizabeth it produces
psychological effects maybe you're just
a purely physical being there's like a
higher animal doesn't think so
God thinks that in addition to this this
physical world experience now seeing
here you know dissect in the laboratory
theorize about a psychologist criminal
justice majors we are also these these
free beings
this is the entire reality now you can't
see or hear or smell or or feel you can
only think this but this is there and
you exist over all of us you're not just
a very very complex biological machine
you also have very well and there are
certain laws that operate over here
certain you know general rules that we
can we can learn through science through
psychology through economics through
biology all these sorts of things and
what happens there is some rule applies
to too often we behave in a certain way
what it means to have free will is you
can actually determine what you're going
to do the the will is so radically free
that can not only choose between two
alternatives placed in front of it and
you know you can you can be placed in
this situation you know keep taking the
heroin and feel a little bit better or
try to kick the habit or you know
somebody holds it under your hat either
do it I say or I'm going to kill you you
can choose between those two
alternatives the free will is so free it
not only does that it can choose what
it's going to be you know I saw this
many times in the class before the dog
doesn't think to itself it might a good
dog every single one of you because
thought to yourself at some time
probably you know fairly recently am ia
good person and you've maybe looked at
yourself at one point and said I'm not
the good person I'd like to be I need to
do something different that is your free
will because part of what you were
changing was your will itself what it is
that you choose what
that you commit to what it is that you
decide gets priority and what you
sacrifice to them that's part of what
makes you so valuable a dog can't do
that
this is this iPhone can't can't do this
even if it became you know super complex
like you know the Terminator robots that
are self-aware and all that it would
still be lacking this element of
freewill you know I know the movie The
Terminator Arnold Schwarzenegger
Terminator it does like seem to change
and decide things but but it's just
following programming isn't it's
actually still the guy that human being
reprogrammed it and sends back to do do
something so cut says we can't you know
we can't sense this we can't actually
see this but we can think this and this
is what it means to be part of Kingdom
events it says you can't actually prove
in any sort of rigorous way that you
have freedom but you presuppose that you
have freedom in all the actions and all
the choices that you make you behave
like a being that has freedom and that's
enough to elevate you from this purely
mechanical level even just the thought
that you've got freedom means that
you're no longer just something of the
world you have a dignity or value that
says that goes beyond that you're not
just a pilot you know very complex meat
and bones put put together
let me go back now to
to a second size
if all this is a case
and the goal is to be autonomous and to
respect the autonomy of others how do we
do this what are what are our principles
well you know we could just sort of
stumble along and as the English say
model through it or we can have some
sort of principles that we use some sort
of guidance and Khan says there's two
kinds of principles all the way those
that respect autonomy and knows what you
actually place us in a kind of hetero
those that would respect an autonomy
would be the categorical imperative
Kingdom events a little bit hard to
reply but those other two ones that we
had all those examples for compensate
that's how you do that
that's how you maintain autonomy is
about respecting human person property
is when you allow something else to run
the show Khan says that there are four
kinds of heteronomous moral principles
and he's got special permits for these
and and you don't actually have to worry
about
I always know my spellcheck picks that
one up constantly whenever I use that
word I'm always getting just feel like
I'm almost about to get it right yeah
it's probably good you know the worst
thing but I learned too by the way it
tells me what I've got a word wrong but
there's no actual like correct the
spelling
so so I'll type something at several
times oh that's not it that's not it
either
that's not it either what the hell is it
so I have to go into word define what
did the actual like smelling it or don't
ever like cool over so I can tell you
did you mean the correct yeah that was
our shrimp no I've never done that that
would that would actually be a good idea
okay now when you talk about something
being impure what what do you associate
that word cuz you've heard that word
okay
numbers and science yeah and I think
that's that's a useful way to think
about this particularly what we just
talked about this world over here
experience comfortable more to
experience or to put to the test and we
often talk about empirical studies so
you get you know a control group and
then you give this other group of drug
and you see what happens to those things
differently here than they do here and
you're looking at experience right now
your experience of the world has not
been very scientific so far did you get
science class you put things in test
tubes right there's most your life's
been measuring things and applying the
scientific method that's been sort of
you know looking and seeing what happens
you know when you were a kid you learn
early on if you react in certain ways
you'll get punished and if you acted in
other ways people will like you and
they'll treat you nice and you know
could that be different yeah if you went
over to some other kids house and then
you were surprised that some of the
behavior that they did they didn't get
punished for what's going on here and
you may have gotten experience to say
wow here I don't like being punished I
want to be able to get away with doing
this and at Johnny's house they do this
all the time or you might have felt like
there's something wrong in this place
why aren't they punishing them what's
wrong with these parents and then the
you know maybe you know what's a Johnny
went to Susie's house and Susie got a
and nobody said good job or you know
took her out for dinner at her favorite
place or water or CD or anything like
that they just that's what's expected of
you and you're like plus that's not very
nice at all I don't like this place
but these empirical you know warrant
punishment things going well for us
going down the for us that varies very
much from place to place a situation a
situation if you grew up in a
well-adjusted household your experience
of what you think people are like and
how people ought to behave is very
different than somebody who grew up in a
totally dysfunctional abusive
well sure but that's sort of like saying
you make the best of it
where's all the protection dysfunction I
bring this one I was just sort of
example saying is that the empirical
varies from from the place to place and
if it focuses on what works you're right
I mean some kinds of some cultures will
reward certain kinds of dysfunction like
our American culture is very properly
centered very well sir yeah it's kind of
crazy behavior to to work yourself to
down and ignore your kids and not take
vacation when you should but Americans
do that well that's still from a strict
perspective dysfunctional isn't it
Europeans most European countries start
off with a lot more vacation they look
at what we do is crazy how do you put in
so many work hours you should treating
this the Europeans have problems of
their own they have their own peculiar
types of dysfunctions Wow take a lot of
breaks there and work
yeah it's all experienced today yeah and
they're having immense cultural problem
in figuring out how to maintain European
culture so yeah there's certain kinds of
dysfunction that could work
there's still dysfunction you transplant
them somewhere else they're probably not
working for him
flop them down over here kind of Trading
Places thing and either he prospers
because that dysfunction actually pays
off even better here or it's a total
catastrophe you know now he has to
rethink his life this is all empirical
stuff and kind of says there's two ways
you can you can get your rules for how
you ought to act when it comes to
empirical stuff and one who's based on
what he calls the principle of pride and
happiness and you can call it crude is
pride that he just means your own entity
that's right
so you figure out well if I want to get
good things on life I better be a nice
person so that people will reward me and
not punish me and not taking away the
stuff that I've got or this one
opportunities for me and so I'll do the
right thing like not lie cheat and steal
but I'll do it because I'm being prudent
that way I'm maximizing my pleasure
minimizing my my likely thing doesn't go
away it does because it takes duty and
it subordinates it to happiness you're
right this is not what these easy
advocating saying this is heteronomous
is a little bit better this is actually
depending on feeling not a lot better
but at least you know I mean think about
the person who sort of cold and
calculated Lee tallies up the goods and
the bads the pros and the cons about
whether they should cheat under sponsor
right and now imagine somebody who
doesn't cheat on their spouse because
that would make them feel bad which
person would you say in the better
person I would say myself in the context
it says yes slightly better the person
who doesn't cheat under spouse because
they feel that would be a bad thing
they can feel wrong or bad or something
like that okay or maybe they feel good
about not cheating other spouse right
rather than the person who says well all
things being equal it's less of a
winning proposition for me to cheat on
my spouse for me to stick with never
notice though if you like when you
depend on the feeling your feelings stay
the same I don't have you have any
relationships where you knew that you
love this person so much they're so
attractive everything that they have to
say is so interesting we can't wait to
get them to know them more and more and
you know find out everything about them
and you know you go through that period
what do we call that say honey what's
taken yeah can't you Asian yeah these
are a whole bunch of names for this and
does it last
no even with the person that you're
supposed to be with it doesn't last like
that time and you know you have to
actually make a couple that are like
stay together for a long time they have
to make efforts to to recover that to
remember why they got involved with this
person the first place your feelings
about right or wrong they're not that
reliable because they're feelings
feelings come and go what happens when
you get burnt out I think some of you
had experienced this maybe that work
previously maybe right now the students
are a little bit burned out and you say
yeah you know I really liked what I was
doing before
now I don't is that a reliable guy for
what you've walked up in as soon as you
stop feeling what you should feel it's
gonna be over so that's not going to be
a very useful principle for morality and
that's cover on Thomas that's that's
allowing something about you your
feelings to run the show or allowing
some sort of calculation about your
happiness juror on the show when he's
talking about rational principles what
he means by that are ones that we're not
getting by just looking at the world and
doing sort of trial and error and
generalizing from our experience these
are things that we can actually think of
and this is tapping into something
that's more who we are and use English's
between what he calls the principle of
perfection and then what he calls the
theological principle and in this class
you notice there's there's something
called the divine command theory that I
put something about either this is where
we're first running into it
confident is not recommending it he's
actually saying this is what started it
so the the theological principle is
where you get your rules not from
yourself for some reason
some other principals who talks about
rational I suppose these are not based
on experience these are based on sort of
ideas that we have and one of these is
the notion of perfection or I would say
if you want to translate this into our
own terms today call this utilizing your
human potential and the other one he
says yes to do with some sort of divine
command and he says what he calls the
theological consumption if you think
about that
says what would God be God would be like
a perfect being God would have a perfect
will you know we don't always do the
right thing we feel duty to be kind of
an imposition on us not just an
obligation but an imposition good we
want to do other things though so I you
know show up here even if I'm not
feeling about my desires and
inclinations that just state that you
know where if I don't come in I have a
duty I have another duty right to call
you or to let you know you know through
Miami or something like that that we
don't have class we just show up here
and there's no sign on the door if you
sit here for 15 minutes and you say what
the hell and then you leave be kind of
upset didn't you may be happy also would
you be upset with me
you think I didn't do what I should do
I act out of duty going against my
inclination so are you right now but you
know those of you who aren't eating we
prefer to be walking so where you're
acting against your inclinations you
didn't what you ought to do what God
wouldn't be constrained by anything like
that right if God is perfect
think about the way you think of God
usually God's will wouldn't have any
sort of things interfering with them
got another perfect world I wouldn't
feel duty God just do the right thing on
that and God would also presumably that
command us to do the right thing so if
you love your neighbor because God told
you to that's acting on a geological
conception that's for calm heteronomy
you're not loving your neighbor because
that's the right thing to do and you
recognizes your you're sort of pushing
it off one step and saying I'm not smart
enough to figure this out on my own all
rely on some some divine
okay so this is what we call the divine
command theory development it's kind of
saying that's that's a form of
heteronomy that's that's pushing off the
responsibility to figuring out
the other one it cause the principal
perfection
he says
the problem with it is that it's empty
and indefinitely and here is targeting
something like Aristotle or Plato the
virtues are forms of human perfection
perfection doesn't mean like everything
is completely imperfect he means sort of
like an active process of becoming more
and more what one want to be do you feel
that some of you probably feel this way
you have a certain potential and your
potential is being born more realized
you feel this in your major while you're
studying there yourself to be requiring
greater and greater capacities and it's
not just like something coming in from
the outside but you you find something
within you responding to it something
that you might say unfolds who you are
you didn't realize when you first came
to Paris that you had long business or
fashion or criminal justice or whatever
else so much but now you're finding
parts of yourself in that discipline
because that would be realizing your
human potential and you've had that
experience not just in a manger angle
but also with your friendships you've
become friends with people and you've
realized parts of yourself that you
didn't know we're there maybe you know
it's not like they weren't there before
there is lying there latent and being
involved with that person brought out a
side of yourself that you like there
might be some debris outside don't like
that spirit I get rid of those friends
but that was helping you realize your
human potential what we're going to look
at with virtue ethics is realizing human
potential as well
you know Plato thought to be a really
human person means to be just means
remember back with the parts of the same
and everything is working well that
would be what conscious talking about
the perfection and context that this is
in some way is too too vague too
unpredictable
so that's also every Romney as well the
only thing that's going to be a guide
for morality for conte is to be
autonomous and that means to for reason
to recognize it's all rules and you
accept that some number the categorical
imperative so that's what I'm going to
leave off there's a lot more I can say
about conflict yeah it's not a cop class
in scope if you can I encourage you if
you have any questions about this
material in particular
bring them up because this is this
difficult stuff I think is very valuable
even if we don't agree